all right post super bowl dude real
question
what happened to all the movie trailers
that used to come on super bowl games
really i mean i'm not gonna say there
weren't any movie trailers but some of
the ones i was really hoping for that
had a good shot nope snyder cut trailer
nope venom let there be carnage no
mortal combat nope
is that movie really coming out mommy
and punks it's slated to come out what
next month there's no trailer i feel
like it's an internet troll joke and i'm
i'm
falling for it it's weird there were
some other trailers but of the trailers
i saw falcon and winter soldiers the one
i want to talk about which isn't a movie
it's a series but
hey trailer nonetheless so in the
trailer to falcon and winter soldier you
see these two friends
who have always acted like friends like
dude we're cap's best friends which
makes us friends
then cap retires and they're like we're
more like frenemies
i mean you know they're still friends
sure but you know they have a staring
contest
falcon's all showing off like hey i can
fly jumps out of the plane
what can buck do in this trailer you
really see buck got the short end of the
stick
falcon has wings he has the cap shield
he can
fly what did buck get but yeah you're
gonna say oh he has the cool metal arm
that's an interesting way of saying he
lost his arm in the war
buck lost his arm and got brainwashed to
murder people but he does have the best
stamina of anyone i've ever
heard of because he just spent four
hours [ __ ] kansas city
oh those were the bucks nut buck it's
different
so captain buck and captain falcon team
up to be like falcon
punch which is there a captain america
football team
well it's official anyone who chose team
cap
they won but it sounds to me like zemo's
back that voice sounds like zemo anyway
what does he say is like i must complete
my work or something like that
i have no intention to leave my work
unfinished well buddy of the two lead
avengers you pitted against each other
one melted his brain with the infinity
stones and the other enjoys a night of
settling down to a cup of tapioca
pudding after a riveting game of bingo
i'm pretty sure your work just kind of
completed itself the world's changed my
friend the world has changed right zemo
let me give you some pointers you don't
take on the ip itself you just talk some
[ __ ] online and get the fans to fight
each other that's how you do it i've
been on youtube for over a decade now
i've seen some [ __ ] also hey that's
zemo's masks that i didn't notice until
i was editing this video so here's a
voiceover filling in that gap although
speaking of bucky's brain programming is
that still a thing i mean it's easy to
look past it you know because he's
he's a good guy now right and he's been
a good guy for a while he's just kind of
been a victim of his shitty past but if
that manchurian candidate [ __ ] was
around in his head
all those decades later you could still
activate it with a series of words at
the time of captain america civil war is
it still there because if so yeah baron
zemo's
that's a pretty that sucks all zemo has
to do is have a good memory you could be
like i don't have the book anymore but i
remember the words the butcher the baker
the candlestick maker whatever the words
were
and bucky's like alright falcon let's
fight i challenge you to a staring
contest it's either gonna happen and be
a problem or it's gonna happen and we're
gonna be made to think it's a problem
but it's gonna be like malcolm reynolds
when she would tell edgy for
supposedly paralyzed him then mal's like
ah
yeah i moved that nerve so it's just
gonna be a total fake out like that and
bucky's gonna be like oh yeah
in wakanda they totally reprogrammed my
brain
to never fall for that again so yeah the
falcon and winter soldier trailer it
looks entertaining and it holds to what
disney plus
has been doing with star wars marvel
where it's like
yeah that that feels like a movie but
it's a series
i will say this being a series i hope
the episodes are
longer than a half an hour it's like
when something this grand in scope and
scale has
30 minute long episodes which let's face
it one third of that is zen credits
it gets me invested enough weekly to
it feels like weekly edging you know or
is it the trailer for falcon and the
winter soldier have you seen it why did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you